the electron transport chain is a set of
enzymes which is located on the inner
mitochondrial membrane and it is the
main source of energy in the aerobic
pathway of energy generation hello guys
and welcome to met simplified in this
video we will study about the overview
the concepts the role of various enzyme
complexes and energy calculations in the
electron transport chain before
beginning make sure to hit the subscribe
button below for all the upcoming videos
from math simplified and also make sure
to hit the like button on our Facebook
page for all the flashcards and other
stuff before watching the video on
electron transport chain also make sure
to watch the videos on krebs cycle
glycolysis and beat oxidation you can
find the links for the videos in the
description of this video
now let's talk about the overview of the
electron transport chain first
the mitochondria has a outer
mitochondrial membrane a inner
mitochondrial membrane the space between
these membranes is called the inter
membrane space and inside we have the
matrix of the mitochondria if we look at
a close section of the membrane
structure of the mitochondria we can see
the structure of the electron transport
chain so here we have the outer
mitochondrial membrane the inner
mitochondrial membrane the inter
membrane space the inner mitochondrial
membrane contains four sets of enzyme
complexes which are named from one
before in Roman numerals the matrix of
the mitochondria also contains numerous
other cycles like Krebs cycle and beet
oxidation if you have watched the video
on these topics you know that these
cycles produce reducing equivalents
called nadh and fadh2 these reducing
equivalents contain electrons which are
donated to this set of enzyme complexes
the electrons then travel from the first
to the fourth enzyme complex and in this
movement energy is generated this energy
is utilized in pumping hydrogen ions
into the intermembrane space from the
matrix of the mitochondria this
continuous pumping of hydrogen ions into
the intermembrane space causes the
generation of a higher concentration of
hydrogen ions in the intermembrane space
as compared to the matrix of the
mitochondria this generates a positive
charge in the intermembrane space and a
negative charge in the matrix of the
mitochondria this is called the
electrochemical gradient the hydrogen
ions cannot cross against this
electrochemical gradient because the
inner mitochondrial membrane is non
permeable to ions so here we require a
special transporter
the enzyme ATP synthase comes into play
the ATP synthase transports hydrogen
ions into the matrix of the mitochondria
and uses the energy generated from the
flow of hydrogen ions to phosphorylate
adenosine diphosphate into adenosine
triphosphate this is the basis of
generation of energy in the form of ATP
which is a currency of energy in our
body now let's talk about the various
electron transport chain complexes what
you see here is the inner mitochondrial
membrane which has these electron
transport chain complexes these
complexes are numbered from 1 to 4 in
Roman numerals and in addition to all
the 4 complexes we also have two
additional prosthetic groups called the
coenzyme q + cytochrome c so let's first
talk about the complex number 1 the
complex 1 of the electron transport
chain is named as NADH dehydrogenase
complex it is also known as the NADH
oxido reductase the first complex is a
l-shaped protein complex which is
present in the inner mitochondrial
membrane it has two arms the vertical
arm is located inside the inner
mitochondrial membrane whereas the
horizontal arm is located inside the
matrix of the mitochondria it is very
easy to understand the function of any
enzyme of electron transport chain by
just understanding its nomenclature so
the complex one is called NADH
dehydrogenase complex because it is a
dehydrogenase which removes hydrogen it
removes hydrogen from the reduced form
of the nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide
and it is called a complex because it
also contains flavin mononucleotide
and iron sulfur compounds
it is called oxidoreductase because
dehydrogenation is an example of
oxidation reduction reaction the main
job of this complex is to receive
electrons from nadh and transport it
further to the electron transport chain
now coming to the complex 2 of the
electron transport chain the complex 2
is called succinate dehydrogenase
complex it is called a dehydrogenase
because it removes hydrogen from
compounds in this case it will remove
hydrogen from the succinate and oxidize
it to fumarate which is a step of the
krebs cycle and similarly it is called a
complex because it also contains iron
sulfur clusters in addition to succinate
dehydrogenase the second complex is a
part of kreb cycle which catalyzes the
reaction for oxidation of succinate to
fumarate in this reaction the reducing
equivalent fadh2 is produced which is
utilized for donation of electrons in
the electron transport chain the complex
3 of the electron transport chain is
called the cytochrome reductase it is
also known as the Kew cytochrome C
oxidase now cytochromes are a group of
proteins which have heme as their
complexes or the prosthetic groups they
also have iron core in which the iron
can exist in an oxidized or reduced form
depending on the electrons it has the
complex 3 contains three types of
cytochromes the cytochrome B cytochrome
C Vann and cytochrome C the main job of
the complex 3 is to accept electrons
from the electron transport chain and
then transport it to the cytochrome C
the cytochrome C then transports these
electrons to the complex 4 of the
electron transport chain the complex 4
is called the cytochrome C oxidase
it is a heme and copper containing
complex whose main job is to oxidize
cytochrome C that is to receive
electrons from cytochrome C and then it
uses those electrons for the reduction
of oxygen to water a hence it is called
cytochrome C oxidase in the next video
about the electron transport chain we
will study about how exactly the
electron transport chain works and I
will also study about the various energy
calculations in electron transport chain
thank you so much for watching this
video make sure to subscribe us on
YouTube for all the latest videos and
also make sure to follow us on Facebook
for the latest updates you can support
mathema fight by buying on any shopping
website like Flipkart amazon ebay
Snapdeal and many other sites to the
affiliate links given in the description
below whatever you buy a small
percentage of that will be donated to
met simplified which is used for
covering the cost of equipment softwares
and maintenance of this channel you can
also donate directly to math simplified
all links are given in the description
below